I think you both have psychic ability  and I think that's why we're probably  here right now I'm definitely here  because I'm hosting the show you're like  I'm here cuz they they asked you to be  here yeah but they chose one would be  true they chose you oh let me do this  well yeah we'll beat her we don't want  to upset your mouth but she's a psychic  yeah she just read a psychic man you saw  her visuals be like I almost believe her  more than I believed you know her so  that makes it easier I just I know how  her own over her vibe she gives me  psychic you give me no factories ha I'm  a psychic actress that's what I'm known  for  I give more actress